oh hello there this is Meg for movie
clips with our holiday gift guide where
we give you some gift suggestions to
give those loved ones over the holiday
for all you movie buffs out there the
Indiana Jones films on blu-ray this is
the first time that each individual film
has been released on hi-def blu-ray now
every film lover can pretend that the
Kingdom of the Crystal Skull never
happened if you're looking for something
for the kids we have two great options
to occupy the little ones this season
first up despicable me 2 me me me me
despicable tease time is good and we
likey second pixar's monsters University
if you're looking for the perfect
combination of laughs and heart there's
really no better place than Pixar for
the action lover the ultimate macho
movie of the year fast and furious 6 in
memoriam of Paul Walker watches action
fest filled with charismatic
performances and great car chases Priya
boyfriend the hangover trilogy have him
watched that while he's working on his
own holiday hangover for your girlfriend
the twilight forever blue right box set
all five films on blu-ray with a ton of
extras in a beautiful case this will
keep her swooning over Edward and Jacob
to the new year haha a comedy pick is
Edgar Wright's cornetto trilogy shaun of
the dead hot fuzz the world's end it's
like what 23 punch a comedy gold this
will keep you laughing your heads off
while your uncle's get drunk and argue
politics if you're looking to fulfill
your superhero needs we have two great
options for you first up man of steel
now you can watch the destruction of
metropolis from the comfort of your own
home second The Wolverine Shh this one
has a superb character work and awesome
action sequences that were missing from
x-men origins looking for something for
the entire family the perfect pic is the
hobbit an unexpected journey this
charming lighter look at Bilbo's
adventures has a brilliant cast and
fantastic set pieces I'm talking to you
Goblin che sequence for you hi
salute an indie film aficionados we have
the critically acclaimed ain't them
bodies saints the feature debut from
director david lowery this film stars
rooney mara and casey affleck is two
lovers brought together ripped apart by
a common crime not really a feel-good
holiday pick but definitely one worthy
of your time it's our last pic [ __ ]
something not quite movie related but
definitely worth your time the Breaking
Bad box set the groundbreaking series
reaches conclusion this year so anybody
who wants to relive the magic or catch
up this is the perfect holiday gift for
them this was mega movie clips with our
holiday gift guide comment below and let
us know what's on your list this holiday
season thanks for watching and everyone
here at movieclips wishes you and yours
a happy holiday